nicolas vidal directeur de publication
de putsch médias bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
aurélien dachier quitte son parti la
rave la création d'un neuvième groupe
parlementaire cela révèle quoi selon
vous pour en marche
pour bruno renaud dachy si la position
est pas très clair finalement parce qu
ils déplorent l'ouverture du parti qui
se dit que vers la droite il est l'homme
de gauche
or on aurait peut-être aimé qu'elle
revienne à celle hors du coup politique
de trafalgar du 49 3 eh ben il puisse
peut-être claquer la porte
on rappellera aussi que il tient
énormément à l'écologie aurélien tâche
et il faut lui rappeler qu'elle que le
23 juin 2019 pour aller me cacher il a
voté pour le traité de libre échange du
ceta vous savez ce traité entre l'union
européenne et le canada
donc finalement c'est un pour moi cette
espèce de faux départ ou un pas de côté
fictif pas sûrs qu'ils quittent la reine
pour aller pour allait devenir la porte
parole et il est jeune et je vais vous
dire en plus ce très sincèrement mon
opinion je pense que les français
concrètement le départ de ray la tâche
et il s'en moque un peu mais ça c'est
toujours intéressante pour nous
éditorialistes ou commentateurs
politiques de voir ce que ça peut ça
peut donner comme lui et comme comme
idée et puis il se revendique de la
gauche au run est haché mais de la gosse
de quelques hommes de celle qui a voté
même dans la main avec la droite le
traité de lisbonne en 2005
donc tout ça est une nouvelle fois je
trouve un coup d'épée dans l'eau ou du
moins une petites manigances politiques
on nous a parlé nous en impose et avec
la loi de roumanie terre les plages
dynamique et là on a maintenant
l'assemblée nationale dynamique
voilà un peu mon avis mon regard sur ce
départ de leur tâche et et jeudi pour le
dernier poste ce thème la coriandre
hachée il quitte l'arène mais finalement
il a dit qu'il resterait quand même donc
pas dans la majorité mais du moins il se
répand dans l'opposition donc vous voyez
tout ça n'est pas très clair chez aurait
bien de tâches et vous parlez d'une
assemblée nationale dynamique et fun 9e
groupe parlementaire
comment vous analysez vous son arrivée
dans le paysage politique bon alors je
sais pas si c'est la fuite des cerveaux
et mais au moins c'est la majorité
buissonnière 1 qui s'effrite depuis un
certain temps et le tort de cette
majorité très sincèrement depuis l
élection de manuel macro et depuis la
mise en place de cette majorité
parlementaire l'assemblée nationale il
ya quand même
physiquement la conscience politique du
militantisme aussi est fondamentalement
je pense de la conviction chez la
plupart des députés la raim qui sont
issus du corps social vous savez nous a
fait la grande théorie du corps social
des gens qui étaient pas de la politique
mais plus plus sérieusement que je pense
très sincèrement qu'aujourd'hui la
pression de la rue la pression populaire
la pression sociale commence très
sincèrement à se faire sentir dans les
bandes assez nationale on le sait on le
sait tous et toutes depuis deux ans
c'est une succession de crises les gilet
jaune la réforme des retraites
maintenant la crise du coc vide donc
tout ça aujourd'hui commence à vraiment
à mon sens se faire sentir chez les
députés et peut-être que député ils ont
compris peut-être qu'ils étaient il se
sentait un peu les obligés des français
1 et que la fonction devait l'emporter à
mon sens sur la personne c'est à dire
l'intérêt des français est aujourd'hui
avec les lois qui sont en train notre
passé dans une assemblée dégarni on peut
se poser des beaucoup beaucoup deux
questions est-ce que vous vous pensez
qu'avec la création de ce nouveau groupe
parlementaire la reine peut perdre sa
majorité au sein de l'hémicycle alors
mathématiquement si ça se fait le perdra
sa majorité mais vous savez très bien
quelle sera rattrapé par les 46 du modem
et les 10es de la dizaine d'agir donc
concrètement le père drame elle pourra
rallier peut-être ça mais concrètement
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que au
delà de cet effritement de la règle
d'ailleurs il est il est engagé depuis
six ans un certain moment il ya eu
beaucoup de départs de quoi que
là-dessus ce que ça me montre très
sincèrement c'est cette fracture majeure
entre la majorité des français et le
pouvoir politique et la classe politique
et ça c'est extrêmement importante parce
que j'ai l'impression que même pas j'ai
l'impression je suis j'en suis sûr que
manuel macro va avoir de plus en plus de
mal à gouverner
à la sortie sacré du courant d'un virus
on a vu d'ailleurs alléger les jeunes
qui ont tenté de reprendre les rues
hier pardon au samedi les soignants qui
appelle vous l'avais dit dans votre
sujet précédent
les soignants qui appelle à une grande
manifestation médiation en général donc
tout ça va être très très compliqué et
en plus bon emmanuel macron avec sa loi
d'urgence sanitaire tout cela n'est pas
fait pour apaiser le pays et on notera
aussi son rapport à la souveraineté
française qu'il essaye de dire comme
l'espèce demandera de plus en plus
régulièrement et notamment son hommage
au général de gaulle aujourd'hui on sait
que manuel vacances et pas le gardien
des tops de la vision gaulliste ou alors
puisque vous parlez de son hommage au
général de gaulle il a entamé
effectivement aujourd'hui la première
étape d'une série de célébrations en
hommage à l'homme du 18-juin vous y
voyez quoi vous dans cette démarche du
président alors il nous a aidé les
éléments langage ministériel nous ont
dit que c'était c'était du symbolique et
pas du politique
enfin aujourd'hui quand on parle de
souveraineté européenne depuis septembre
2010 est je crois pas que le général de
gaulle aurait souscrit une seule seconde
une seule virgule une seul mot de la
vision de là franck cammas manuel da
cruz de la france pour la faire je le
dis souvent sur votre sous vos antennes
la faire passer sous les fourches
caudines de l'union européenne donc je
trouve effectivement cet hommage au
général de gaulle et beaucoup ont été
ont critiqué cet hommage là moi je ne
comprends pas très sincèrement parce que
la vision que des fins emmanuel macron
de l'union européenne de ce monde
néolibéral qui met en adressant la
souveraineté de la france je vois pas
comment très sincèrement on peut faire
un hommage au général de gaulle même si
on doit des tâches et le symbolique du
politique très sincèrement je trouve ça
assez malvenu
merci beaucoup à vous nicolas vidal je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur de
publication de putsch médias merci merci